during the Blitz Buckingham Palace was
bombed whilst the king and queen were at
home the delayed action bomb is falling
outside Buckingham Palace the home of a
beloved sovereign and his consort in
damage there may have been some cynicism
but the bombing of Buckingham Palace
helped transform Bertie's image as king
through that bombing of Buckingham
Palace he can make this claimed having
suffered and to understand what people
are going through there's great approval
for them not sending the two princesses
away to Canada they've stayed in Britain
and they're sticking it out with
everybody else and that is really really
helpful for his individual popularity
but also for the monarchy as an
institution Mary visited bombed-out
Sheffield Manchester Leeds and Coventry
George made frequent visits to the East
End and the King a protective father
would allow his fourteen-year-old
firstborn to make her very first
broadcast to evacuate
I feel that I am speaking to friends and
companions thousands of you in this
country have had to leave your homes and
be separated from your fathers and
mothers my sister and I feel so much for
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]